[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the cowell theater at fort
mason center before we begin we'd like
to remind you that no food or beverages
are allowed in the theater
and in consideration of your fellow
audience members please turn off your
cell phones and pagers
also please take a moment to notice that
there are emergency exits on each side
of the auditorium your nearest exit may
be behind the section in which you are
seated the cowell theater thanks you for
your cooperation
[Music]
good evening
i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at the long now foundation
and uh thank you all for coming out
i know coming out to live events is uh
is a special challenge these days so
give yourself a round of applause for
coming out appreciate it
federal government often gets the most
detention
and strangely it's the local and the
state governments
that have the most power
and effect on our lives that's
especially true in the recent weeks
um it's also why i'm very excited to
welcome our speaker tonight michael
tubbs who
started his career as the youngest mayor
in the country and did some of the most
radical and interesting experiments in
local government than we've that we've
seen so far
and uh the person who connected us
michael mcafee my friend from
policy link where he's the ceo and
president is going to be joining on
stage for the q a after the talk so
please
fill out your question cards sorry fill
out your question cards as clearly and
legibly as possible and make them
short uh and we'll have the lights will
come up a bit for that as well um if you
can make them short and legible they'll
have the most likelihood of actually
getting asked welcome michael tips
well first good evening
so good to see you all and i'm sorry you
have to hear my voice for the next hour
but i'll do my best
to make it as lively and energetic as
possible
and i want to start our conversation
today
um with an acknowledgement that is such
an incredible privilege
to have the space
to have the time
to have the mental capacity
to think about the future
um we know that brain science tells us
that poverty and facts
and makes it difficult to do long-term
thinking
that for the six million californians
living in poverty or the 37 million
americans living in poverty not to
mention those who are one paycheck one
sickness
one coveted diagnosis away
from losing two weeks of work and being
plunged in poverty themselves that this
idea of long-term thinking is something
that neurologically is very difficult to
do because it impacts sort of the
ability of the brain to think and plan
long term so i want to center our
remarks on the future
with the acknowledgement that the future
we deserve is impossible to build
without everyone being part of building
it
i i submit to you as i start our
conversation today
that a lot of people today
in san francisco and stockton and los
angeles throughout the state and
throughout this country
are living a nightmare in the present
that's the result of someone's dream of
the past and what the future could look
like if we don't want to repeat the
mistakes of the future then we have to
make sure that everyone has the ability
to be part of what the future um for for
our great state and for our country and
our society
looks like
and i also stand before you today i
think
as one of many examples of what the
future can look like
um 32 years ago i was born in poverty
and in one of the poorest cities in this
in the state stockton california with a
mother who was 16 and a father who still
is incarcerated and 32 years later i get
to give talks about the future i was a
mayor i
get to advise the governor and i say
that to say that we're missing on so
much potential
so many dreams of what our society could
be like
because so many people are trapped in
the present and a very
what
um peace theory jonathan ghoul training
talks about that structural violence
because of the avoidable environment of
basic human needs in the present
uh so to close the loop on this private
conversation i just submit to you today
that the future we deserve
that the future we need that the ability
to imagine a society as it should be
predicates on the decisions we make
today particularly around the issue of
poverty and the avoidable impairment of
basic human needs in our state and in
our country
and when i think about sort of how do we
design the future or what does the
future look like i think of a story my
grandmother taught me
my grandmother is is the holiest person
i know
what's today thursday wednesday
she's probably at church or watching
church if it's any day into the wild my
grandmother's at church and and and
growing up
um she taught me this parable but i
think everyone knows pretty well she
said one time there was a guy walking
down the road or he was on the horse
going down the road
and as he was walking he was beat up
left on the side of the road to die he
just got hijacked ambushed he got robbed
and she said that a
priest walked by
and saw the man on the side of the road
and said well hmm
maybe god ordained for this person to be
on the side of the road
maybe there's nothing that can be done
maybe that's divine that this particular
person was on the side of the road
and then she said another person walked
by maybe it was a politician
walked by
saw the man on the side of the road
and said clearly this man chose
to be on the side of the road
if this man wasn't lazy
maybe he could pick himself up by his
bootstraps and get up
from the side of the road
maybe if this man was smart
he could find a way to get a job to pay
for a horse so he could get up from the
side of the road that if maybe this man
had worked harder in school or if this
man
had been at the right place at the right
if he had just made better choices
he would not be left on the side of the
road
and then she said a samaritan came by
and saw the man
on the side of the road and sort of
got down from his horse got down
it's probably a woman actually think of
the story like a
good samara samara woman she got on the
side of the road
um bandaged his wounds made sure he had
a nice room at the presidio hotel and
made sure he was
he was good in in and on his way and i
think oftentimes
when we think of policy
that or we think about the future we
think the future requires all of us to
be good samaritans and i submit to you
today that even that's not enough
and that's not enough because if you
look at the road in which the story took
place at jericho road it's a narrow road
that's conducive for ambushing
the road is known as the bloody past
meaning that a person on the side of the
road wasn't abnormal
that a person on the side of the road
wasn't
surprising
that in fact by design the road was
designed in such a way for there to be
people left on the side of the road and
i submit to you as we think about the
future it's not enough to to think about
being good samaritans it's not enough
and it's important for all of us to
understand our common humanity it's not
enough to believe in this notion of
universal human dignity but we have to
do the hard work of restructuring the
road because again this road was
structured for violence
that no one should be surprised to see
person on the side of the road when
there's
easy places for robbers to hide an
ambush where it's narrow and it's hard
to get help and i submit to you today as
we think about the future the president
is
is a good teacher and that all the
outcomes we complain about
to the crime you guys talk about and the
drug use and the tenderloin to to the
educational outcomes we see to to
um there was just a smashing grab at the
chanel store in la yesterday that all
these things are actually predictable
based off how our society and the
present is structured
and that's what
i tend to call the the setup so i'm
gonna spend a couple minutes just to
list a couple of the actions of
government
of the folks we vote for uh the things
we pledge allegiance to that have
created the outcomes we complain about
and so bear with me as we go through a
little history lesson
on what we know in terms of that the
present we inhabited was based off
actions of the past
and we know that in 1492 some folks came
over here
and displaced a whole nation of millions
of people indigenous people and stole
their land
we know that in addition to that land
theft and genocide there was also 400
years of human trafficking
400 years of free labor that created the
wealth and created many of the
industries we enjoyed today and helped
submit america's standing as as the
leader of of this current world order we
know that even after that we had years
of redlining where certain neighborhoods
where certain people left had homes that
were deemed less valuable just because a
banker made a red line that said you
can't invest here you can't invest there
we know that during the great depression
that everyone felt there was a new deal
that was struck and that deal
said that some people
can get gi benefits even though all
people
served in war
that that some people will be able to go
to college that some people will get
housing loans that some industries would
get new deal benefits and that some
people wouldn't and we know that
hundreds of years later we have a a
wealth gap
between the races that hasn't changed
since 1964.
we know hundreds of years later
the same people who had their land
stolen from them
have terrible outcomes we know hundreds
of years later the same people who who
worked for free for 400 years and were
trafficked and raped and brutalized
have terrible outcomes we know that 400
years later we have those same folks
doing similar types labor in our prison
system
fighting fires
doing municipal services all for below
the minimum wage and we know that if you
look at any indicator
of success and in the indicator of
failure if i showed you a picture if i
showed you a neighborhood if i showed
you a street
everybody in here to a t could guess
which
what's successful quote-unquote and and
what's not and then i'll submit to you
today that that drake drake what i
described as a draconian present
is because of the imaginations of those
that are able to create the future that
we inhabit today but the point of this
talk is to give cause for optimism
and what i'm optimistic about
is this idea
that we can redesign the road in the
future
that we don't have to have a road or a
society or a country structured for
inequitable and equal outcomes that
there's literally things we can do
not with a magic wand but with hard work
and with truth to create a future that
again that we all deserve to live in and
before going to the policy prescriptions
let's talk about the truth
because we also know that in our society
a big part of the way this road is
maintained and graveled and made sure it
it stays the way it is are the lies or
the narratives we tell about how we came
to be
we know it's hard to solve the issue of
poverty
if the ubiquitous thought is that people
are poor because they want to be poor
we know it's impossible to create a
future free of poverty
when we believe that people are poor
because they're dumber than people with
money
we we know it's difficult to to to
imagine or create a world or a future
free of free of the um
avoidable impairment of basic human
needs
when we believe that somehow that
there's a natural order to things that
somehow this hierarchy of human value we
tolerate our society is okay so the
first thing we have to do when thinking
about the future is tell the truth
and the truth is this
talent and intellect are truly
evenly distributed but resources
opportunities are not
the folks i went to school with at
stanford weren't necessarily smarter
naturally biologically genetically than
the folks i grew up with in stockton but
they had the best schools the best
teachers the best summer enrichment
programs the
the best tutors for 20 years after
already being born with an
insurmountable head start we we we know
that the truth is that we list miss out
on so much
just recently in the new york times
there's an article about the einstein
called the einstein effect and it talks
about how
low high performing and math um
low-income children
were less likely to get inventions and
patents
than lower than the worst performing
rich children
and that's not a question of merit
that's not a question of ability that's
a question of inputs resources and in
structure but that is something that
that we're able to change and we know on
the policy front what works particularly
for the issue of not having money
and it's not
teaching people how to manage money they
don't have
it's it's not mentorship
it
it's not um unpaid labor
it it's not a minimum wage that is lower
than the cost of living in every city in
this country
but it is cash
and one of the things i did in the in
the old days
when i was still an elected official was
we gave people money
and this was in 2017
before the pandemic
before my good friend andrew yang before
we had 80 mayors as a part of marriage
for guaranteed income before we had 100
guaranteed income pilots going on in
this country before san francisco had 12
pilots happening here in the city and it
came from this realization number one it
came from the imagination
of someone who grew up in poverty
it took someone who grew up in poverty
to start the first basic income program
in the country and i just want to pause
there for a second because i think it's
again it's incredibly important in this
conversation about the future to
understand that those
most impacted by the problem
have solutions
they have answers they have the radical
imagination needed to liberate us from
from from some of the nightmarish lies
we've all internalized it was really
that lived experience that gave birth to
this idea that let's try giving people
money and and what we saw is is no
surprise because people are people
we saw that people spent money the way
you and i spend money because people are
people they spent the money on their
kids
they spent their money on utilities they
spent their money on food they spent
their money on getting their uniforms
clean and we also saw that the money
did not make people stop working
wow
that that
that that the 500
was not enough for people to stop
working instead what we saw
is that people were able to work more
because we saw that for folks living on
the margins for folks living in poverty
that five hundred dollars was the
difference between affording child care
or not
that five hundred dollars was a
difference between be able to get your
car fixed or not that 500 was a
difference from being able to take time
off your job
where you don't have paid time off so
you can't go interview for a better job
without the risk of losing money and say
you know how much bet on myself
and go ahead and do
an interview and get a full-time job
that pays more and allows you to work
less as we saw time and time again and
and five years later now we have again
80 mayors who are saying yes let's
figure out what guaranteed income looks
like we had a child tax credit
which cut child poverty in half and
somehow folks in dc thought that was a
bad idea and so let's
with inflation coming let's cut this in
the child tax credits to make all the
kids poor again we we um we we have we
have momentum around this idea and i
think the future has to be one where we
all agree that no one
should be poor that no one
should live in poverty that no one
should be homeless and if those sounds
like radical notions
they're not because you don't live in
poverty
you don't live in scarcity
you don't live unhoused and and
unsheltered
so if it's good enough for you
it should be good enough for everyone
that's not saying everyone needs the
same
but it is to say like what type of
future would we have
if not one that understands that
everyone has the same basic human value
and everyone needs at least a baseline
level of security to be human
that everyone needs at least the basics
shelter
food
water the ability to pay bills and again
we have policy tools that work and the
question is how building the political
will to get there and again i think that
goes back to the narratives around how
do we talk about the present and how do
we talk about the future and who do we
allow to participate in the conversation
around planning for the future
like i'm all off my notes so i don't
know what slide i'm on let's see
well y'all know california has a lot of
money i don't need to young san
francisco y'all know that
um
another
policy solution we can do that will
literally end the wealth gap in this
country
will be baby bonds it's been researched
it's been
um theorized there's literally bills and
state legislatures just literally bills
in the u.s senate now that says if you
put just a little bit of money a little
bit of seed money in a child's account
when they're born
and you let it grow
by the time they're 18 years old they
had i see bob freeman here a real leader
in this space so thank you mr freeman
for your work on this that that folks
are giving
children have assets so that the
mistakes of the past don't have to
dictate or or or narrow their future and
and again we know what it can do there's
been models there's only bills in
congress now there's a bill in the in
the state legislature that just passed
at least for kids with covet but this is
something we can do today to prepare for
a future where if there's gaps in wealth
they're truly gaps based off ability if
there's gaps in wealth they're truly
based on gaps in effort
not based off gaps in government
intervention not just not basing gaps of
marginalization but but that's really
based off merit and i think i'm having
this argument with one of my friends who
thinks about the future differently than
i do
is that what i'm saying we should want
for the future
isn't equal outcomes
but just ones i'll say it again it's not
about
equal outcomes it's about just outcomes
it's about outcomes that are
predicted by the just inputs we put in
and not these wild outcomes we pretend
are based off merit that we pretend are
based off ability that we pretend are
based off how everyone's working because
that creates the dysfunction
all the isms the anxiety the the stress
um that that plagues our society far too
long
um
are far too often today so as i draw to
a close i i would say that
i am more optimistic than ever
the more i think about the future for a
couple of reasons
reason number one
being this idea that
this present was created by people
this present was created by folks who
had dreams and imaginations and values
now i think if we stick to what we say
our values are or as dr king said if we
stay true to what we say on paper
we can really build a future that looks
like our values of opportunity of
liberty
in in an injustice for all and and
number two i'm incredibly
um optimistic about the future because
for all the ways in which the present
isn't what we want to be
sometimes i i get heartened with
thinking about
the past was even worse
like for for all the ways in which
um it feels like we're moving backwards
from the the the the very real
consequences of the roe v wade decision
recently
um to the very real consequences of
getting the voting rights sack
um to to the very real real consequences
of
attempted coups and insurrections there
was actually a time in this country
where things were worse
um
and
things only got better
because people even mired in this
function of today
did what this foundation does did what
you all do and step back and said okay
but what can tomorrow be
and and also it's it's incredibly
inspiring because
we have the opportunity to bring other
people into that future planning process
to really speak from experience about
sort of how the future could look
different particularly for those on the
margins because and i truly believe that
literally
the the cure for
and lord knows we need one the cure and
i'm not a biologist so it's not possible
just just bear with me it's a thought
exercise that the the
the cure for covet
the the look at some of you guys like
please now the the
the the next invention to make our life
easier
it's not
on sand hill road
it's not
in the presidio it's probably some
little kid in hunter's point breathing
environmental toxins it's probably a
young person in south stockton hearing
gunshots at night it's probably a young
person in watts i'm sleeping hungry that
that when we leave so much on the table
not just for today but for tomorrow by
allowing the mistakes in the imagination
of the past
dictate how we live in in the present so
as i conclude 10 years ago
12 years ago
i was on the freedom rides with some of
the original freedom writers
and
it was i reflect on this often because
these were like i mean they're older
folks now but when they did this they
were 19 20 21 years old they literally
signed their wheel before going on the
bus
and and one guy looked at me we're going
through
we just lit we just left when the
penitentiaries in mississippi
and he looked at me and he said michael
i was arrested on august 4th 1961.
why is that day important and i said
well you were arrested if you weren't
arrested i wouldn't be here thank you
i'm so thankful for all the
opportunities like you did that and he
looked at me
and he said no son on that day
barack obama was born
and then he said he had no idea
and that's what's so beautiful about
long-term thinking and future planning
and that's why
everyone needs to be a part of it
because there's something hopeful and
prophetic about it and he said he had no
idea that the choice he made on that day
would pave the way so that 50 years
later a child born with no opportunity
a child whose birth was illegitimate in
some states because
his father was black and his mother was
white
would have the chance to be president
and then he looked at me and he said
what are you prepared to do today
so that's 50 years from now a child born
in poverty has the opportunity to be
president and
i think that's really the question that
motivates the great work of this
foundation
it's not just about 50 years or 100
years but 10 000 plus years of magnitude
and and the question really is it's not
going to be one person
or one dream
or one leader that's going to save us
it shouldn't be
10 people or 20 people that are planning
the future
can y'all imagine if it was just elon
musk thinking about the future like
no offense i'm sure some of his friends
are here he seems lovely um
um
but um
but it's on each and every one of us
every day
to think about what our values are
and we line that up with the answer to
this question what are we prepared to do
today
so that 10 000 years from now
there's a society there's a country
there's a civilization
that looks back at this day and wonders
how do they think that
that looks back on this day and last and
say oh my gosh they allowed that to
happen and what are we prepared to do
today so that tomorrow
all the things are imperfect today seems
silly
seem adequate and they in the bright
tomorrow that we create is something
that our future
descendants 10 000 years from now viewed
as inevitable
like how do we create a society that 10
000 years from now
those who look as us as ancestors and
reading about us in history books
look like we look sometimes and say oh
yeah this is always going to change this
is always going to happen like
eventually they figured out that women
should have the right to choose full
stop that that no one should be poor
that no one should be hungry that no one
should be in house and that answer to
that question really lies in what we do
each and every day so thank you all for
what you're doing thank you all for what
you will do and looking forward to the
rest of our conversation
[Applause]
uh
good evening
my name is michael mcafee and i'm going
to be in conversation with michael i've
got some questions from the audience and
we'll get more so if you have questions
write them down on the cards and i will
do my best to make sure that we get
through them
it's good to be with you brother always
good to you
i wanted to start with you you used a
word that i think
is important when we think about lung
now thinking you use the word prophetic
and when we think about
poverty
and we think about what you do i want to
start with the person first
what do leaders need
to be able to do the prophetic work of
liberation because
ending poverty
is a liberatory act
and so when you think about that what
advice do you have for us around
what do leaders need to do in their
person
to be prepared to do this work
and i know it's not absolute and it's a
journey but
what do you recommend we start no i'm
pausing cause that wasn't in the
questions you sent me so let me think
you know i have to just i i'm just
ripping off warming up
no but but in all seriousness i i think
that um
part of it has to be disengaging from
what's possible yeah and we're having
the conversation before the talk about
how the impossible happens
and i actually think you have to look at
reality for what it is
and there's a delta between what it is
and what it should be
but you can't be dissuaded with how big
that chasm is or how big that delta is
and
mary wright elderman one of my mentors
she told me
when i was on city council and i was
already tired i'm like this is crazy
stuff like i'm i'm good like what's what
like how did you do this for so long
yeah you know it's like literally my
first year in city council i was like
how'd you do this and she said
it's a privilege to struggle for justice
because you're not by yourself a and
it's a relay
so even if you don't get everything done
in your turn or everything done in your
time you have to trust that there's
gonna be someone else
to pick up the baton just like you were
the answer to someone saying he's
looking at the baton for me and that
that so i think it's having that long
now thinking as well that it's not just
you but in the time you have
you have a role to play
and that role and what you do in your
imagination can't be tethered strictly
to what's what seems possible or
convenient or expedient which is what
people really mean when they say
possible it's like what's comfortable
what's not sacrificial and what's
convenient
um but know that to get to where we need
to be that you have to take some swings
you might miss and and
i think you also though have to
when we had the first meeting for my
staff another one give people money and
my staff they all act like they're on
board now they was like you crazy we're
not doing that right right
um and i told them i said but you guys
we have a responsibility if the status
quo is fine
let's find something else to do like
this is not fun if everything's okay i
really do something else
um but if the status quo is untenable
then we have to do something we have to
try and innovate and experiment and be
willing to be wrong and to be willing to
lose so i think the answer to your
question after that
meandering jericho wrote it was
um
you have to be
so
brene brown said like this she said you
have to be really concerned with getting
it right
versus being right
like getting it right like trying versus
having the answer and when you do that
it relieves some of the fear that gives
you the opportunity to explore because
again
the fact that you're experimenting means
no one has the right answer yet so
you're going to be just as right or
wrong as everyone else at the worst and
at the best you can at least point a lie
as to what what
what could work or what could this a
possible solution be that's right
you know when you think about what you
did with guaranteed income
it is um
it moves beyond charity
and when you talk about upsetting the
setup
that upsets a lot it upsets the
non-profit industrial complex
if we all fell in poverty we would not
say
um
tell me the 20 agencies i should go see
we would say let me have a little gas
keep it in my car let me keep my lights
on and let me do that
how do we go from where we are at now
where we have a charity mindset
we have that samaritan mindset versus
the mindset that is necessary to
reimagine government systems reimagine
non-profit systems to do the most
elegant thing which is directly put cash
in people's pockets
i really
believe
it it stems from
this and it's no one's fault we we we
grow up in a society where it's
programmed enough and
ingrained in us
that if folks have less something's
wrong with them
that they're the problem
and until we really recognize that even
behaviors are dysfunctional or behaviors
that are abnormal
are in effect and not the cause the the
the effect of a dysfunctional society of
dysfunctional community of something
that was broken before the person was
broken until we really get that
we'll continue to have these solutions
that again position the person as a
problem i say that because
before we're doing the guaranteed income
work
before we're doing the guaranteed income
work i actually had internalized some of
those thoughts myself
so when we first were thinking about it
before i committed to do it i had to do
some wrestling with myself like
can we really give these people like
don't get just give people like it took
me a while to think and in the course of
the interrogation i i again had to
challenge myself and say well what
sort of biases have you picked up for
being in this be in this society and
and why what what about you
makes you better equipped to spend money
than someone you don't know that's right
well you know let's let's stay on the
ubi um
ken i believe it's broad asked the
question
um isn't the focus on ubi misplaced
given that the cost of living is so high
here
shouldn't the focus be on cost of living
so
ubi or a guaranteed income
isn't a panacea
far from a magic bullet
and we have to be able to walk and chew
gum and do multiple things at once so
the the powerful thing about
guaranteeing incoming universal basic
income um
one of them is this idea of income
volatility
that
particularly if you are one paycheck
away or two paychecks away from poverty
your income is incredibly volatile
depending on on the circumstances
um it regards the cost of living like if
you're
tire bust if your
kid is sick if you're
um
you need to take time off work etc
and the guaranteed income helps or
smooth that so it builds economic
resilience
in in addition
um there's
to deal with high cost of living you
could deal with the drivers which we
should i bring the cost of living up
you can also make sure people have more
money to help pay for those costs so i
think
in a way
as solutions go a guaranteed income
may be not a perfect solution but if
there's one thing to do maybe the best
solution to deal with
all the ways in which lack of cash makes
life difficult for folks
thank you
you know kevin kelly asked the question
what other solutions are there and i
want you to respond to something in
relationship to this question
sometimes when people ask me what are
other solutions i say the first solution
should be to stop harm
to see the systems of oppression that
are right in front of you that are
undercutting this good work say like a
municipality that chooses to
enact excessive fines and fees in poor
neighborhoods right things like that you
were talking about the design of
oppression
so what are some of the solutions and
how do you help people see
just the design of cities and states
that are automatically undercutting all
the good poverty work anti-poverty work
yeah um so the la times had a lot of
solutions are so simple the l.a times
had a really good article today
about homelessness
and
the shocking conclusion
um
was that the biggest predictor of
homelessness in the community was
lack of affordable housing
that um chemical dependency definitely
was an issue that's not clear if that's
the cause or the effect
um
that
mental health issues definitely
i'm an issue but the biggest predictor
of there's gonna be homeless folk are
folks that are homeless excuse me was
lack of affordable housing so one
solution would be
build affordable housing and make it
affordable to build affordable
affordable housing
we talked about baby bonds um another
sort of
solution
would be we we know
what the cost of living is or at least
what it costs to rent a one bedroom
apartment
and we know today that in 99 of counties
in the united states the minimum wage is
not enough to afford a one bedroom
apartment
um so another solution would be
a a minimum wage that allows people to
pay for minimums right like
yeah um
another solution is we have
sort of
particularly women who do caregiving
um in in domestic work if you do it
next door you could get paid but if you
do it in your house you can't
and then if you decide to work but you
work minimum wage
your entire check goes to child care
which is why so many women choose to
leave the work for our course to leave
the workforce to stay at home and not
get paid to do the hard work of
childbearing because they went and this
is like
pay child care workers enough
have child care
count if you take care of and be paid if
you take care of your own children
um on the criminal justice reform like
we we know that
or let's do foster kids i know
homelessness is such a big issue we know
that 50 of all foster children will be
homeless at some point in their life
why is that are they born inherently
homeless are they born with an inherent
desire to live on the streets or is it
because they're kicked out of the system
when they're 18 with no support to no
resources let's so
and
the ant it sounds simple because it is
the answers are simple implementing them
is difficult don't get me wrong but like
the answer isn't a mystery like you
don't need a
genie like the answers are very clear
it's just building the political will
to do it because the answers aren't free
in some cases
um
but we also pay for
what we see like we spend trillions of
dollars on
poverty
every year
but there is a dominant logic to what
you're saying that is going to require
some long down thinking to change it was
government that built the white middle
class gi bill fha those types of things
we now say government can't do this we
can't afford it so how do we make this
bridge you were talking about not making
the mistake
of all about what's beautiful about that
because i know i was in a conversation
with some other folks about this and
they thought i was like attacking them
i said i've never been a hater i
understand government could do it for
you and your family let's look for
everyone's families like we know you
could do we know it can happen let's
let's do it for everyone like i love i
love that for you i do but let's do it
for for everyone right
yes um
so
but but i think to your question and and
i
tried to talk about a little bit of my
remarks and probably should drill down
more but i think part of it is the
narrative like when we're talking about
long now thinking it's like what's the
mindset that you have
in you as you think about the future
because if your mindset is one of
scarcity if your mindset is one of
again hierarchy if your mindset is one
of
sort of
the world is arranged the way it is
by the invisible hand
of god and market
who just created all this craziness like
then the future's gonna look crazy it's
gonna look like this like right yeah but
on mars or something like what's that so
i i i i
i think we have to really do the work of
just really interrogating what we see
and really asking the question why but
it's so hard we're so busy and we're
working and we're building and we're
doing that to take a second instead of
like being mad
or angry or next door
um
you say well huh
did this come to be if it's oh and and
then you say this and and ashley glover
blackwell says this all the time
we also have to have relentless honesty
because i keep hearing nostalgia for a
time that never was
like i'm not like
like this again
like not like let's go back again now
let's make this great again
when
and for who
yeah right because
and again to the to the beginning of
your question there there's countless
examples in our country's history
where our country was great for some
folks it had great policies for some
folks and now the rub or the issue is
that how do we send that greatness to
all yeah and i think that's there's like
a narrative thing or i think a mindset
thing we have to really interrogate
because again the issue isn't capacity
or ability
we can't do it the issue is around who's
deserving and who's not
and and and
and and
once you got yours should no one else
have any and i think that's the kind of
some of the fights we're having right
now
do you think we have enough pain for
getting to the all that solidarity you
know
here in the bay
no matter what color your skin
folks struggle even when they're making
good money because of
you know those sins of the past we we
abandoned the public good of
education public education so now if you
live in the city you got kids you got to
make a choice can i afford private
school or my rent or my mortgage because
many cases you would say public
education is not the best option so i
have to pay for it
so do you think how much more pain do we
have to experience as
one path to getting to solidarity or is
there another path
that is a good question um
because it's actually wild how
widespread the pain is and how we still
have such polarization i'm like yeah i
get it you could
hate my music but come on like let's fix
it like
you poor i'm poor like there's something
in common
let's work on that um so actually
michael i i don't know i don't know
what it will take you would think a
global pandemic would do it
like
you would think like literally the stock
market crashing in a way like yes
literally like the biggest employers in
this country saying government we need
bail us out we have nothing yes you
think
um a summer of
people of all races taking to the
streets
saying black lives matter we have to be
better you you
i don't know what what what could be
worse like i know i'm scared about what
like
what are the other options in terms of
what's what's enough for a wake-up call
yeah and i think that's why the work of
this foundation and the work that you
all do that policy link is so important
just to show people beyond like
being human and nice and kumbaya like
this is about survival that's right this
is about having a future
this is about having a country a
republic a democracy
so i'm gonna keep talking about it but i
i actually don't know what it's going to
take i hope it doesn't take too much
more i i can't do more that's right um
of this craziness we need like i need
let's just fix it before it gets worse
that's right
well let's move into a little bit more
exploration of some of the solutions you
know leela asks us we we know
guaranteed income works
so
how do we overcome the objections to it
and and until piggyback on another part
of this question someone else asked
what cities do you think have the
greatest
promise
for having a breakthrough
so i turned down a job after i lost
re-election in the white house
because i looked and i said hmm
that senate doesn't look like it's going
to be the type of city that's going to
do things we need done
and i said but california
there's no excuse
because you don't have
any opposition party it's
a one-party state
and
one party talks about being for liberty
and opportunity and progressive and that
which is small with that
but highest rate of poverty so much
housing unaffordability and sheltered
individ people who are unsheltered etc
so i decided to stay in california to do
the work of in power of california and
marriage for guaranteed income based in
california
because i want to see it as a political
issue
it's the issue that there's just a
political party who doesn't believe in
that or is the issue something else it's
the issue that
regards that political party there's a
comfort with poverty there's a comfort
with hierarchy there's a comfort with
sort of some people doing really really
bad as long as i feel good and that's
what i'm trying to interrogate so i'm
very hopeful about california actually
because it's my only hope um
in terms of how to get these things done
and then i
think for all the answers to the
question about like we know what works
why not we know what works why not
there's probably a more
deliberate and didactic answer but i
think the short answer is
this country
our policymakers and our history
suggests that we are fine giving money
to some folks and not to others and
we're fine with some folks being poor
and that makes people very uncomfortable
to give money to
women
for example and in fact many people are
arguing that the
roe v wade decision and the assault on
the human rights of women are
particularly as women are making gains
and economic parity in the workforce
right like because they have agency over
over their body and decisions they make
or because we're giving money to black
people because black people are lazy and
don't want to work and spend money on
alcohol and jordans
and people tell me that people would
tell me that all the time with basic
income they wouldn't say black people
they would say you know people huh we're
going to spend money on
talk about me like yeah yeah that's how
i got these you're right um i spend
money on shoes like you do you have
shoes on too anyway
um
or we're uncomfortable giving money to
like
immigrants or like
we just have a discomfort with affording
to some folks basic human dignity and
just the benefit of the doubt that we do
to others and that's why for
like literally we ended a
child tax credit
yeah for like
for parents with children we said you
know what after we did it and it worked
we said you know what
despite what you said
i know in west virginia my folks are
spending the money on like joe really
anyway
supposed to be non-political stop asking
me these questions
well let me ask you this last political
one we're getting close to time but matt
thompson asked the question
if this was implemented how would it
change our politics
so think of just what you said in
california how would that change it oh
if which was everything was implemented
yes let's say we were successful with
implementing guaranteed income oh just
guarantee that again i have a big list
how's okay
cause we know we got to get to all of
that right yeah okay like if we if i'm
gonna guarantee income i will retire and
be like you know what someone else can
talk now i'm good
when things off the list no um
it would change our politics because a
more people will be engaged because more
people will have positive interactions
with government
if you're economically insecure
etc your relationship with government is
usually punitive it's usually you need
to come to this court day it's usually
you have to get your car it's about to
get towed it's usually oh this bill etc
versus like oh my government sees me
believes in me i have a it's and we saw
that in some of the data and stuff and
that people had that more positive think
thought about government i think it
would also help restore trust in
institutions that that folks would be
like oh okay
this thing works it's what it works for
me my my tax i see
more of my tax dollars coming to me and
that's a good thing i think it would
allow people to engage in politics we
know that in our country
money is a proxy for time i can't go to
city council meetings i can't go to this
commission i can't volunteer here and
volunteer here because i got to work i
got to eat i don't have to pay time off
and i think and we saw there's it's no
surprise
or it shouldn't be a surprise
that
the most intense years of labor
organizing
of unionization
have been the last couple yeah because
hey there was a a pandemic but b people
had more agency because they were had
stimulus checks they had the child tax
credit they had the golden state
stimulus they were able to
more in a
more powerful or palatable position to
bargain and to collectively bargain and
to say you know what actually i don't
because
people always talk and one of the things
we should debate all the time was this
notion of the dignity of work yeah and
that like
you're digging that people want to work
because that's how they get their
dignity and what we've seen
is that actually people have inherent
dignity
and if you give people a floor it allows
them to negotiate to be treated with
dignity at work right and and i think
that's how government would change with
the guaranteed impart
well we're at time i'm going to ask you
this last question and
as i asked you this question i invite
you to just leave us with a parting
reflection on what we can to do to
support this work or anything else that
you like malcolm says and i'm going to
read it exactly as malcolm wrote it
he says have you thought about running
for governor senator
[ __ ] it president
to take your vision nationwide
[Laughter]
[Applause]
well thank you malcolm
so i was lucky enough to spend
eight years
in local government
in my good years in my 20s
[Laughter]
prime
party years i spent
no taco tuesdays i was like city council
for hours
um
and i say that to say i really enjoyed
it and
clearly i believe that government is an
important driver for a lot of these
things and
i turned 32 in two weeks
um
so
i've hopefully i've been working on this
stuff i have a lot of life
ahead so i'm not in any hurry to run for
anything again i actually enjoy like
no i'm like to talk like this when i was
still married too but in my head i think
i talk more freely no i'm not
elected so i i know that i'm committed
to working on these issues
but right now
it's outside of government which is fine
for now and
if it makes sense in the future to run
for something i would seriously consider
it but i
truly love
being ex-mayor
[Applause]
hilarious brother
thank you will you all give
michael a hand
thank you
thank you
appreciate you brother
[Applause]
[Music]
you